[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 20 décembre
2016 bienvenue pour cette édition du 7 8
les inviter celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité dans le département à
l'honneur aujourd'hui vous entendrez
jacques pelletier c'est le président de
la communauté de communes de la haute
vallée de chevreuse il sera question
d'écomobilité son agglomération vient de
recevoir le trophée des territoires
électromobiles et puis bernard pivot
également le journaliste homme de
lettres est actuellement sur scène il se
raconte à travers ses différents
spectacles
il était donc à saint quentin en
yvelines il ya quelques jours et il nous
a accordé avec quelques instants bonsoir
jacques pectine sur ce plateau vous êtes
le président de la communauté de
communes de la haute vallée de chevreuse
intercommunalités qui couvre notamment
saint rémy le mesnil saint denis ou
encore dampierre et bien sûr chevreuse
vous venez de recevoir le trophée des
territoires électromobiles catégorie
villes de 25000 à 50000 habitants parce
qu'il ya plusieurs catégories pour cette
distinction est ce la couronne le
lancement du service d'éco mobilité
sociale est partagé vous avez lancé
c'était en octobre
en quoi ça consiste ce service d'éco
mobilité sociale est partagé
concrètement le si vous voulez vous être
monté un petit peu à l'origine puisque
si ce système a été inauguré récemment
c'était le 8 octobre en nullité et on
nous avons commencé à travailler sur ce
sujet là en avril à 2015 et nous sommes
allé assez vite
en réalité à cette époque l'ademe lancé
un appel à manifestation d'intérêt pour
l'implantation de bornes vous savez
qu'en france on veut développer les
voitures électriques dont donc il faut
des rechanges des moyens de recharge
ces bornes c'était le problème de
l'ademe développer à l'horizon de 20 ans
7 millions d'ordres allons nous on a
fait quelques unes
dans le même temps la région ile de
france elle était intéressée par l'éco
mobilité la facilité de déplacement un
de nos conseillers
qui s'appelle christian müller a eu
l'idée d'associer ces deux idées c'était
bien d'avoir d'un côté des bornes de
l'autre côté de mettre en place sur
chacune des stations d'écomobilité une
voiture qui serait en écho partage je
dois dire que le système lancé est un
système expérimental nous avons deux ans
d'expérimentation au terme de quoi on
verra comment ça marche et comment ça
peut évoluer
l'idée c'est quoi les bornes pour
recharger des voitures de monsieur tout
le monde
la voiture elle est partagée donc c'est
à dire que nous avons une plateforme
et si demain vous voulez prendre la
voiture vous inscrivez sur la plate
forme et vous répondre vous pourrez
prendre une des voitures qui est située
sur l'une des 16 aux stations nous avons
mis en place c'est aux stations sur
l'ensemble de la communauté
la deuxième idée le côté social qui est
don dont le père est christophe muller
que j'ai déjà c'était il ya deux minutes
la deuxième idée c'est de dire mais
puisque nous avons ces voitures nous
avons forcément la communauté des
personnes qui peuvent être en
difficultés de mobilité par son âge et
par s'assure pas de permis de conduire
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de voiture parce
qu'elles ont eu un accident une jambe
cassée ou que sais-je et l'idée c'est de
créer un groupe de personnes qui se
déclarerait volontaires pour être
inscrits sur la plateforme et qu'ils
seraient d'accord pour passer du temps
avec ces personnes désireuses de vivre
ces personnes voilà qui veulent accéder
à ces véhicules à ce mode de déplacement
s'inscrivent également sur la plateforme
dire que la plateforme du travailleur
qui va les aider qui va absolument
elle y aura un pool simuler la personne
qui va commander le transport sarah
celle qui en a besoin mais elle aura en
face d'elle un pool de gens qui se
déclare pour d'accord tient madame ou
monsieur appel at elle besoin
eh ben je suis disponible cet après midi
je peux en plus je peux l'emmener quitte
moi même à fuir une course dans un
endroit donc si vous voulez savoir le
partage et en même temps l'aide à
d'autres personnes voilà voilà la barre
et voilà la base du système on est sur
le respect de l'environnement on va
protection de la planète sur le véhicule
électrique et puis sur du social et un
bien social même retrouver aussi avec ce
système l'antenne que cette idée est
bien là parce que dans nos territoires
ce sont des territoires ruraux même si
les communes de saint rémy chevreuse et
le venus à nice gagné commune
relativement dense il n'empêche que
notre territoire de la communauté de
communes de la vallée de chevreuse
réputé comme un territoire rural ce qui
signifie que en termes de transports en
commun
certes il ya bien les gars de serre émis
les chevreuse et de la verrière en toile
et d'oeil à 20km une ligne de mu mais
c'est tout dans notre idée en scéne y
avoir des stations qui sont disséminés
sur le territoire peut permettre sans
doute d'énerver plus finement le
territoire pour amener les transports un
petit peu un petit peu plus près des
gens encore une fois ils nous auront à
déterminer comment la population va
recevoir cette ce nouveau service est
tout sauf parle d'octobre on a inauguré
c'est difficile d'en faire un bilan mais
la dimension très difficile de faire un
bilan si on dé nous avons déjà trois ou
quatre exemples qui montrent d'ailleurs
frappé un exemple dans une des communes
une personne mal an mais malheureusement
au chômage priver de voiture pour des
raisons économiques nous a dit
merveilleuse grâce à la voiture j'ai pu
aller faire tous mes rendez vous
d'embauché sans lesquels sont cette
voiture là j'aurais pas pu y aller et je
lui ai posé la question mais le coup
parce que le nez forcément la location
c'est 7 euros par heure c'est dégressif
si l'émission est depuis longtemps m'a
dit c'est parfait ça ne me gêne
absolument pas j'avais une voiture pour
une heure pour deux heures je la repose
et j'ai un moyen de mobilité
deuxième chose qui nous a paru étrange
aussi deux exemples dans une autre des
communes
un artisan qui a une camionnette pour
aller faire ses petits chantiers et bien
trouve lui dit l'utilisation de voitures
électriques plus commode pour aller
faire cette vie plutôt que prendre sa
camionnette voilà deux exemples qui sont
un peu diamétralement opposées alors je
peux vous dire que mon la personne au
chômage chutent d'un véhicule on y avait
un peu penser la personne par contre
partisans qui plutôt que d'utiliser sa
camionnette utilise une petite voiture
pour aller faire déduit ça on n'y avait
pas pensé
comme quoi la population va pour
s'inventer même le service avec avec ce
système mis en place ce service d'éco
mobilité sociale et partagez vous le
dites on menait encore un petit peu aux
prémices à la véritable allemand à quel
moment il y aura des points d'étapes qui
seront faits comment tout cela aussi est
financé la région est un terminal 1 bien
entendu le alors je répond d'abord à la
première question n'a point d'étape sera
fait oui je pense il faut attendre six
mois
encore une fois nous étions sûr nous
sommes sur deux ans d'expérimentation au
bout de ces deux ans si ça marche pas on
va arranger les voitures les bornes
resteront elles seront toujours
utilisées par la population où les gens
qui passent par ici alors nalement non
encore madame
serviront alors comment justement
maintenant pour répondre à votre
question sur le coup les masses c'est un
investissement global de 500 mille euros
et nous avons été financés pour se faire
par l'ademe au niveau des bornes qui a
mis 96 mille euros la région
ile-de-france au niveau de la mobilité
comme je vous le disais camille 126
mille euros l'état qui a mis cent trente
mille euros avec les aides qui sont les
dotations pour les équipements des des
territoires ruraux par exemple et puis
notre communauté qui a mis 150 mur
aurait effectivement comme vous le
disiez si justement guérit tout ça c'est
des subventions qui dit subventions dit
impôt j'en ai parfaitement conscience
mais s'il me remets au niveau du
territoire l'ensemble de ces stations
qui sont installés non compris les
voitures d'un investissement de 200
mille euros la commune auteur a dépensé
150 euros certes avec l'aide je n'oublie
pas tes tous les subventionneurs si je
peux utiliser ce terme
donc j'ai cité mais finalement on sera
un peu en avance ou on est un peu dans
la ligne car je vous rappelle et je le
disais tout à l'heure que la loi de
transition énergétique demande 7
millions 7 me 7 millions de bornes
d'ardon à l'horizon de dix ans à peu
près et une indication très rapidement
est ce que matt sonore vous avez reçu
cette distinction justement d'autres
intercommunalités regarde un petit peu
ce que ce que vous proposez on a vous
sollicite oui oui on est beaucoup de
gens viennent voir un petit peu ce que
nous faisons au niveau de la ruralité
par ce qui bien entendu les voitures
électriques mais à paris on les connaît
tous dans la ruralité y en a assez peu
donc les personnes au départ ne pensait
pas que le système pouvait se mettre en
réalité c'est bien pour ça qu'il s'agit
d'expérimentations je le répète mais
c'est important parce que est ce que les
gens qui sont répartis sur le territoire
vont s'approprier ou non le système
c'est là que réside que réside la
question alors nous lançons des
campagnes de communication parce
qu'évidemment tout le monde n'est pas
forcément informés de la possibilité de
ce système donc campagne de
communication qui débute maintenant et
point d'étape nous dit j'ai tout à leur
offrant un délai raisonnable merci
beaucoup je rappelle donc ce trophée des
territoires électromobiles pour votre
intercommunalités de chevreuse et ce
service d'éco mobilité sociale et
partager délivré par la verts qui est
une association sous l'égide
ministère du développement durable de la
ministre la dame ségolène royal merci à
vous d'être venu sur ce plateau du 7-8
les invités l'émission qui se poursuit à
présent avec l'homme de lettres bernard
pivot il a joué son spectacle au secours
les mômes ont mangé c'était ce samedi 17
décembre prisma elle encourt une mise en
scène est du livre dans lequel il
raconte la vie d'un romancier tourmenté
par les mots et nicolas landry est allé
le rencontrer
qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve de vous dans ce
romancier alors le début rien sinon le
si la jeunesse
là je vais parce que le reste j'ai pas
fait supérieure de l'edge epl goncourt
je me suis je n'ai pas été reçus
apostrophe c'était moi qui faisais
l'émission donc oui je suis pas du tout
l'homme sauf dans sa jeunesse où je le
montre amateurs de mots
amoureux des mots à travers la lecture
d'un de son copain il a petit larousse
petit larousse et son copain et donc je
moi même quand pendant la guerre je
avait pas de livres ma portée ma
disposition
donc le livre que je que j'ai lu c'est
pas un roman c'est un dictionnaire ses
vieilles éditions du petit larousse et
c'est là où je me suis familiarisé avec
les mots ou où je suis devenu amoureux
des mots de la langue française
j'aime les mots tout simplement parce
que ils sont et ils ont occupé une
grande place dans ma jeunesse dans mon
enfance ma maison je peux dire mais
surtout parce que je trouve que les gens
ne font pas assez attention aux mots
nous vivons nuit et jour avec des mots
que nous prononçons nous entendons que
nous lisons et malheureusement nous
c'est un peu comme l'air qu'on respire
on ne fait pas attention à eux
on s'intéresse à l'air qu'on respire
lorsqu'à une pollution mais sinon
contient pas de pollution
bon on s'en fiche pas mal de l'air qu'on
respire mais assez des mots c'est un peu
la même chose on s'intéresse aux mots
que lorsqu'un seul coup il ya un mot un
peu tragique ou un mot insultant qui
intervient sinon ben voilà on glisse
dessus alors qu'on devrait être beaucoup
plus attentifs aux mots on entende et
des chevaux on entend des fois un
chevaux des chevals l'orthographe
aujourd'hui à souffre un peu quand même
vous êtes à l'initiative du concours le
dico d'or créée dans les années 80 quel
regard vous portez sur ces jeunes
aujourd'hui qui font des fautes
d'orthographe et puis parfois même les
plus grands ouais enfin il n'y a pas que
les jeunes vivent des photographes et
est un peu à peu tout le monde et même
des entreprises qu'ils sont aperçus que
leurs cadres comme était tellement de
fautes d'orthographe qu'ils ont commencé
à leur donner des cours l enfer faire
des dictées donc n'accueille n'ont pas
déjà n'y a pas que les jeunes qui
commettent des fautes mais en soi c'est
normal que nous commettions des fautes
d'orthographe
des erreurs comme ça dans l'utilisation
des mots c'est normal puisque la langue
française n'est pas facile
et puis on peut pas tout savoir mais ce
qui est important et c'était la leçon
que j'ai essayé de faire passer à
travers les dicodeurs c'est essayer de
s'améliorer
essayez de 12
d'avoir recours un peu mieux plus
souvent au dictionnaire des
dictionnaires sont on en revient au
début de ce petit entretien
les dictionnaires ce sont des ddd livre
merveilleux où lee qui renferme plein de
trésors plaint d' aventure et c'est
toujours agréable de se plonger dedans
pour y découvrir un mot qu'on ne connaît
pas l'orthographe d'un mot qu'on
ignorait le sens et où l'essence des
acceptions différentes de dd des mots
des mots parfois les plus usitées donc
ce qui est intéressant de la plus grave
c'est c'est non pas de faire zéro faute
pas c'est impossible je commets des
fautes et je commettrais des fautes si
je n'avais pas recours au dictionnaire
et quand j'hésite et bien je joue mon
petit larousse mon petit robert et je
regarde comment c'est écrit un mot et
c'est ça que les jeunes on devrait le
renseigner un peu plus souvent avec plus
d'obstination c'est ayez recours au
dictionnaire
ce qui me plaît dans twitter c'est de
n'avoir que 140 caractères pour faire
passer une idée un sentiment souvenir
c'est précisément ce cet exercice de
concentration ce terreau fils de de
rapidité dans l'expression qui matent
séduit dès que j'ai dès que j'ai connus
twitter c'est la fin du set 8 invités
pour ce soir rendez vous chaque jour du
lundi au jeudi 18h45 sur notre antenne
pour suivre cette émission d'ici là elle
suivait aussi également les replays
c'est sur notre site internet et sur
notre application mobile à très bientôt
sur tv fils
[Musique]